congratulations to all of you winners
this is really exciting to come to an
award show knowing you've won I know
because I was sitting right in their
seat in 1979 and 1980 and one of the
greatest things about the Student
Academy Awards was the week spending
with the other the other winners because
they became lifelong friends I'll never
forget the first year nineteen
seventy-nine the Academy put us up at
the beverly hilton hotel and we
discovered because we were smart the
trader vic's was connected to the to the
beverly hilton hotel and that we
realized we could charge all the drinks
and food on our rooms so we bonded let's
just say we bonded till we in the
morning till till all the workers there
kicked us out every single night and i
have to admit that we ruined it for
every a student academy award winner
from that year on you can see I'm the
only two-time student Kadim II award
winners so the next year when i won they
put us up at the beverly hilton hotel
and I'm going fellow winners follow me
and we went there but this year they
gave his vouchers
because they said the previous year's
winners spent way too much money at
Trader Vic's so I apologize to all of
the student Kadim II awards for
completely ruining your time no that's
that's not true because this week that
you've had is so special and one of the
things that I learned from the student
Kadim e Awards was seeing my film with a
real audience as a student you don't get
a chance to do that very often and to
hear the reaction of the audience filled
my heart and made me realize that's
exactly why I want to do this for a
living and I will never forgot that
throughout my entire career of making
every film at Pixar the walt disney
animation studio that is the reason why
i do what i do is to entertain audiences
and the first time I experienced that
was here in this theater at the student
County warts in 1979 and 1980 so
congratulations from the bottom of my
heart to all of you you are such
talented talented filmmakers in your and
this is just the beginning trust me
because here at the Student Academy
Awards the the winning animated films
which I get to present I'm so excited
are chosen by judging kind of the
product as a whole right it's a story
and it's the artistic skill and
technical skill you know the animator
working in whatever animation technique
that he or she is chosen this year the
Academy received this is staggering 306
entries in the animation category alone
I think there were there were 45
students in all the world studying
animation when I was studying this is
really remarkable the winning three
films are an object at rest by Seth boy
and Boyden from the California Institute
of the Arts CalArts
follows this film follows some life of a
stone as it travels over the millennia
facing nature's greatest obstacle
civilization soar by Alice to sue from
the academy of art university in san
francisco a precocious young girl helps
a tiny boy pilot yes i said a tiny boy
pilot it's amazing to return home before
he is stranded on earth forever and
taking the plunge mine by Nicholas
Manfredi and Elizabeth kure ho and I
think I blew that but anyway I apologize
they tried so hard
from the School of Visual Arts which
tells the story of a man forced to dive
into unknown waters after his wedding
proposal is put in jeopardy